alors madame la ministre est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite aujourd'hui de la mise
en oeuvre de parcours sup je rappelle
que un peu plus de 800 mille lycéens ont
exprimé leurs voeux est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes satisfaite de
la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
alors je il faut il faut séparer
parcours subset une plateforme et
questionnant elle a extrêmement bien
fonctionné jusqu'à présent les lycéens
ont pu ont pu faire leurs voeux ont pu
finalement exprimé pour la première fois
la réalité de leur choix et la réalité
de leur souhait puisque rien était
imposé ils ont pu avoir pour la première
fois des informations qui était
identique pour l'ensemble des lycéens
et ça je crois que ça a été aussi saluée
par les familles et par les lycéens
eux-mêmes lorsqu'ils avaient dans leur
entourage
d'autres personnes qui avaient utilisé
la précédente plateforme
c'est le point de départ évidemment un
arrangement mais c'est important c'est
important de parler de cette phase
d'orientation en fait qui a qui s'est
tenue pendant toute cette période
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars avec un
véritable accompagnement des professeurs
principaux qui ont fait un travail
absolument formidable avec les lycéens
qu'ils nous ont dit que le fait d'avoir
des groupes plus petit ça leur avait
permis de se mettre autour d'une table
et de parler avec les lycéens de leurs
projets d'avenir chose qu'il n'avait pas
forcément le temps de faire auparavant
et c'est une mission qui leur étaient
pas qui leur était pas confiée
s'inquiètent de ne pas être admis ou
quoique qu'il sera forcément amis ou pas
forcément alors oui je j'entends leur
inquiétude d'autant plus qu' évidemment
là encore un certain nombre de personnes
cherchent à les inquiéter en leur
racontant des choses qui sont absolument
fausses sur sur cette plateforme pour
l'instant les lucioles n'ont pas bougé
vous croisez les doigts
non je croisais les doigts je remercie
tous les professeurs qui les accompagne
tous les jours et qui avec eux ont pris
le temps d'expliquer qu'elle était
l'esprit de cette réforme
l'année dernière on a tiré 65 mille
lycéens au sort pour savoir si oui ou
non ils pourraient aller dans la filière
de leur choix
on les a obligés à 810 1000 lycéens
comment est ce que vous pouvez les
rassurer individuellement d'abord tout
simplement que son dossier puisque ces
engagements soient examinées vraiment
individuellement alors il faut bien
comprendre que cette réforme dans sa
globalité elle a été co construite avec
les acteurs de l'enseignement supérieur
que ce soient les représentants des
personnels les représentants des
étudiants
les chefs d'établissement et tout l'été
toute la durée de cette discussion nous
avons construit la solution pour sortir
du tirage au sort ensemble et pour
commencer à résoudre la question de 70 %
d'échec en première année
tout l'été je leur ai dit est ce que sur
cette mesure là vous pensez que nous
serons en mesure de la mettre en place
parce que c'est extrêmement important de
mettre les lycéens dans une situation où
ils peuvent faire confiance à
l'enseignement supérieur tout l'été la
réponse a été oui j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller dans les universités et de voir
les gens qui sont au travail autour de
ces dossiers pour préparer les
accompagnements pour la rentrée on a
travaillé avec les recteurs et les
présidents d'université des présidents
ont indiqué partout où ils avaient
besoin de place on a financé 19 mille
passes supplémentaires dont mais
exactement là où c'est nécessaire tous
ces bacheliers qu'ils auront une place
quelque part à la rentrée est ce que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui garantir ce que
je que c'est ce qui les inquiète c'est
où est ce que je serai en septembre mais
ainsi si vous me permettez je vais vous
répondre en deux temps d'abord certains
bacheliers n'ont demandé que des
filières sélectives et s'ils n'ont
demandé que des filières sélectives la
chose que je peux leur garantir c'est
que la commission électorale prendra
contact avec eux s'ils n'ont aucun de
leur choix en filières sélectives et
leur fera des propositions au plus près
de leur choix ça c'est la première chose
que je peux garantir la deuxième chose
c'est que pour tous les lycéens qui ont
demandé des filières non sélective nous
avons d'ores et déjà financées
neuf mille places supplémentaires en
regardant très exactement où on avait
besoin de ces places et au fur et à
mesure que la procédure se déroulera
nous pourrons ouvrir encore d'autres
places la seule limite si je puis dire
c'est les murs de l'université quand
toutes les salles sont prises dans tous
les amphis sont son prix évidemment là
dans cette université là ce n'est pas
possible mais on ne s'arrête pas pour
autant
et là encore le rôle de la commission
rectorales c'est de signaler tout ce qui
est possible dans les universités
alentours ou dans d'autres finitions
prochain il ya des délits siens qui
peuvent se retrouver sans affectation en
attente de l'année dernière l'année
dernière d'aménager tirés au sort 65
mille étudiants et il est resté au mois
de septembre 89 bacheliers généraux
parce qu'on n'avait pas réussi à les
joindre
donc si on a réussi à faire ça l'année
dernière avec aucune anticipation
vous comprenez bien que notre ambition
notre volonté c'est que cette année on
sera en capacité d'accueillir chaque
bachelier qui le souhaitent dans
l'enseignement supérieur alors on nous
vous écoutons attentivement madame la
ministre vous parler de l'orientation de
l'accompagnement des lycéens n'est ce
pas mais les français ils ont compris
qu'il s'agissait d'une sélection écoute
et voilà le résultat de la deuxième
question de notre sondage opinionway
parcours sup introduite et la sélection
à l'entrée en fac et bien les gens
répondent oui à 66% voilà c'est ce
qu'ils ont compris alors pourquoi ne pas
assumer madame vidal cette notion de
sélection à l'entrée en fac pour éviter
ce que vous avez rappelé effectivement
la sélection à l'issue de la première
année par l'échec
c'était une question de manque pas du
tout ce n'est pas une question de mots
ce n'est pas de la sélection et quand je
vous parle d'accompagnement en fait ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que
lorsqu'on a le baccalauréat et que l'on
souhaite s'engager donc ses études
supérieures il y a toujours des moyens
de réussir ce sera parfois plus long on
devra parfois prendre le temps de
s'orienter mieux on devrait être
accompagné par des professeurs mais il
n'y a pas de fatalité a échoué dans
l'enseignement supérieur je peux vous
donner un exemple moi je je j'ai
enseigné je voulais dire toute ma vie
est en tout cas toutes tailles et j'ai
tenu à le faire aussi en premier cycle
et en première année je me rappelle
d'une étudiante qui est arrivé avec un
baccalauréat qu'il avait préparé à des
techniques d'analysés médicales elle est
venue me voir à la fin du cours elle m'a
dit madame je comprends pas les mots que
vous employez je comprends pas pourtant
joseph sur j'aime la biologie j'ai fait
ça jusqu'à mon bac je veux y arriver
qu'est ce que je lui dis je lui ai dit
en fait tu es doué et tu sais faire des
choses que les autres ne savent pas
faire tu sais utiliser des pipettes tu
sais faire des examens
donc on va rentrer avec toi par les
travaux pratiques et quand on va rentrer
avec toi par les travaux pratiques
tu vas te rendre compte que finalement
tu peux accueillir arrière et latéraux
rouge et appuyez sur votre expérience
personnelle peut être vous même vous
avez difficilement pousser donc je ne
suis pas un cas unique j'ai fait ça dans
une équipe pédagogique
je connais dans toutes les universités
les gens et pour la seule différence
c'est que maintenant la loi permet que
ces initiatives soit reconnu qu'elle ne
soit pas faite sous forme de bénévolat
ou sous forme de petits
d'expérimentation mais on va pouvoir les
général d'accord parce qu'il n'ya pas
une inquiétude légitime sur les
algorithmes qui ont une part de
l'importante dans l'orientation des
lycéens est ce que vous allez faire
toute la lumière ce qu'on connaîtra
c'est la grande question du moment
comment ses ergots
me fonctionne d'ailleurs il ne soit pas
piégeux je ne sais pas engagé et c'est
prévu par la loi
la totalité des algorithmes seront
publiés donc ça c'est je pense même
inscrit un scribe qui n'existe pas dans
la loi c'est dans le décret
d'application de la loi donc les
algorithmes ne seront absolument connu
et là-dessus j'allais dire il n'y a pas
de sujet pour autant il ya une
contestation des universitaires de
certains d'entre eux à tout le moins qui
refusent de trier c'est leur seller mots
désagréables qui ne veut pas jouer le
jeu
alors qu'est ce que c'est un acte de
désobéissance un acte d'autorité
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ces
enseignants du supérieur qui refusent de
d'étudier les dossiers de parcours si je
pense qu'une fois encore ils n'ont pas
complètement compris quelle était la
philosophie donc ça veut dire que j'ai
pas réussi a alors expliqué qu'elle
était l'objectif
l'objectif c'est en aucun cas de dire
non mais l'objectif c'est d'accueillir
la diversité quand vous êtes en fils on
à 96 mille enseignants et enseignants
chercheurs de l'enseignement supérieur
dans la 400 qui disent qu'il ne souhaite
pas le faire
les autres sont en train de le faire moi
je pense que ces enseignants chercheurs
ils viendront ils viendront aussi parce
que leurs étudiants leur demanderons à
un moment et leur diront mais moi aussi
je veux avoir des travaux dirigés en
plus moi aussi je veux qu'on tienne
compte du fait que j'ai besoin d'être
plus aider pourquoi vous ne faites pas
dans cette filière et le d'accord lundi